we're standing outside the ministry of
Justice tribunal service today as some
of the 200 non-states core participants
in the undercover policing public
inquiry we represent a range of
individuals and organizations working
together including the campaign opposing
police surveillance police spies out of
lives the undercover research group The
monitoring group and The Blacklist
support group
we work to ensure that the voices of the
Spy Cox victims are heard loud and clear
and that this Scandal is never allowed
to happen again
just a few moments ago the chair of the
inquiry judge Sir John mitting released
an important and detailed interim report
on what has been learned so far after
eight years of hearings and evidence
he concludes that the Metropolitan
police's political Spike Ops unit should
have been disbanded 50 years ago that
its activity was a waste of time and
that its intrusiveness and tactics
employed would have caused public
outrage if ever revealed we welcome such
findings
it's been a long and hard journey for
many of us campaigning to expose the
truth which is finally beginning to get
the requisite recognition it deserves
this is mostly thanks to the
determination of campaigners victims
lawyers and some investigative
journalists we have worked so long and
hard for years to expose all this off up
against police denials obfuscation and
obstruction
the shocking reality has at last been
acknowledged the results of the inquiry
so far are devastating for the police
the security services and government
since 1968 the Spy cops infiltrated or
reported on over a thousand social and
environmental groups trades unions
left-wing organizations black family
Justice campaigns and many others
today's report covered just the first
part of the inquiry's work from the
formation of the Spy Cop Squad in 1968
to 1982.
the chair has now set out the inquiry
view on what has been learned so far
about the secret and unlawful operations
the shocking tactics employed right from
the very start and how this Scandal was
backed
and how this Scandal was backed and
covered up for decades at the highest
level of the mix and successive
governments
many of the tactics employed were
absolutely sickening
such tactics included invading people's
homes and lives the abuse of women as
sexual targets some officers even
fathering children before disappearing
stealing deceased children's identities
spying on Family Justice campaigns
compiling information on children and
teenagers sending tens of thousands of
reports to the secret security services
that's MI5
aiding the blacklisting of trade
unionists
taking positions of influence and power
within organizations targeted
and Brazen interference with the justice
system which led to unfair trials and
unsafe convictions
[Applause]
the report is timely as it comes at a
time when the Met has been found by
other inquiries and official reports to
be institutionally racist sexist and
corrupt and remains under special
measures since July 2022
the Metropolitan Police themselves were
finally forced in February to admit that
the spycots operations were quote
unjustifiable by modern standards
however it's worth noting that these
unjustifiable secret operations and
their unacceptable tactics continued for
decades despite so-called modern
standards introduced by parliament in
2000 the regulation of investigatory
Powers Acts
so the judges reports does not assign
blame at this stage but finds that there
were four crucial issues which should
have alerted the Metropolitan Police and
home office to serious problems they
were long-term intrusive and sometimes
sexual Relationships by undercover
officers the legality of entering
private homes without a warrant or just
cause the theft of deceased children's
identities by officers
undercover police taking on positions of
responsibility in the groups they were
targeting and using that to report on
personal details of people engaged in
legitimate activities allowed in a
Democratic Society the inquiry chair
also found that in his views only 3
three groups out of many hundreds were
ever a legitimate Target for undercover
policing of any kind and none of the the
groups are which are involved with the
inquiry the chair stated that these
issues should have been addressed at the
highest level within the Metropolitan
Police Service and within the home
office and don't forget there were
regular reports going from the SDS to
the home office on their activities
annually he concluded the question is
whether or not the end justifies the
means this is judgmenting speaking I
have come to the firm conclusion that
for a unit of a police force it did not
and that had the use of these means
being publicly known at the time the SDS
would have been brought to a rapid end
in the light of the current Spotlight on
the failings of the Metropolitan Police
among the most shocking evidence
released by the inquiry are reports
showing that the Mets explicitly
targeted police accountability groups
included including Family Justice
campaigns like the Lawrence the Stephen
Lawrence Family
Justice campaigns were murdered loved
ones including those killed by police or
racists
our voices This Is Us speaking now as
non-state corporate core participants
the unethical attitude and behavior of
the undercover police towards
campaigners and the language they used
in their secret daily spy reports which
you can all see on the under cover
police inquiry website that the way they
refer to women's bodies the way they
refer to uh to black activists and
Jewish activists that they spied on in
the most racist and misogynistic way
they showed us a contempt for Democratic
rights and for people trying to make the
world a better place this is political
policing we now hear the thoughts of
some of those who were spied on starting
with Jessica from the police spies out
of Lies campaign
thanks to years of support and efforts
by campaigners the authorities are now
on a back foot we are proud to have
helped shift the official narrative from
neither confirm nor deny what took place
through just a few bad apples to some
unlawful operations and now an entire
police force and policing culture that
is rotten to the core and sanctioned by
the state
and this is a statement from Lindsay one
of the core participants who was
deceived into a sexual relationship no
doubt many Undercovers and managers will
be relieved they did not receive
stronger criticism but the evidence of
their own reporting speaks for itself we
see racist sexist and offensive language
regularly being signed off their reports
show the contempt with which they held
campaigners they had no guard rails
whether reporting on children or making
salacious comments on people's sexual
activities all of this was filed Away by
special branch and the MI5
um
you just say your names as well
Jessica please buys out of life
my name is Dave Smith I'm a core
participant I was spied on by the
undercover police because I'm a trade
unionist we're involved in campaigns
against deaths on building soets and for
unpaid wages undercover police officers
were in our meetings we're on our picket
lines were sometimes chaired our
meetings and that information wasn't
just sent to special Branch they shared
this information with a notorious
blacklisting organizations the economic
league and the Consulting Association
the police have admitted that they
supplied intelligence gathered by the
undercover police with major employers
construction employers the mended
thousands of construction workers were
unemployed for years on end this is a
national Scandal this report that's come
out today should be the final now in the
coffin of the Metropolitan Police if I
had an apology we've never had an
apology what they've done but more more
and more reports more and more public
inquiries are finding a map police
institutionally sexist institutionally
racist institutionally corrupt
institutionally homophobic and what this
has done now is shown that anyone
involved in genuine Civic Society trade
unions environmental campaigns political
parties that are perfectly legal have
been seen as a legitimate Target in a
war against their own citizens this is
an outrage and the Met police should be
wound up for what is for what has come
out of this because we're involved in
blacklisting we're also a bit appalled
that despite all the evidence and
despite all the documents uh that
blacklisting has been taken place and
that a police have provided this
information to big business that there
is not I when when the 200 word report
came out I did a word search of it and
there's not a single word in the entire
thing on blacklisting or vetting staff
and that is scary and it's shaking like
that you know this is only the beginning
of the inquiry it's the end of tranche
one there are seven tranches this needs
to be really gone into uh because not
just about the intrusion it's about what
they did to it the real they accuse us
of subverting democracy the real people
who says separate democracy in this
country are the undercover political
police units and they need to go and
they need to go now they call themselves
a special demonstration Squad SDS this
is the state's dirty secret and we don't
want it anymore do you hear
I'm involved in I'm a core participant
both in this tranche and in future
tranches and I think it will show that
I've been spied on since the late 1970s
and I'm sure we'll find that still going
on I'd like to very much endorse what
the other participants here have said
that this is a Vindication for what
we've done it's a shame on Democracy in
this country we heard we hear about Free
Speech all the time but actually it's a
shame on Democracy that these people
have been spying on us I haven't
suffered in the same way that some
people have I haven't had an illicit
relationship I haven't had blacklisting
which has lost me my job but I feel this
has been an intrusion into my political
activity it's been intrusion into my
Democratic right to express myself in
the way that I want to to organize in
the way that I want to and I think we
have to find out much much more I know
the um the swp which I was a member of
then there were loads and loads of
police spies in that organization the
two that I new best we're not even able
to hear their real names we're not even
able to know who these people are even
though one of them has has died this is
something which has been a cover-up
which is absolutely shameful and has
damaged the lives of many many people it
has to stop you seem to indicate that
you think this is still going on
inappropriately what evidence do you
have of that I think it's absolutely
clear that when you look we know that
the future tranches are going to show
much more recent spying on people and
I'd be very very surprised if it wasn't
still going on we know the special
Branch we know there's the secret
services so let's wait and see but I'm
is it ever Justified is it ever
Justified to look at terrorism attacks
for example
in those areas if you look at what
mitting said he said there were very few
examples none of which the people
represented none of which fall into that
category we were people who were
activists political campaigners people
who did all these things for year after
year there was no justification for
doing it I was a friend of Blair Peach
who was killed by the police in Southall
the demonstration in 1979 base five on
the memorial March the following year
and they had lists of what nearly 200
people who participated in that
demonstration many of them friends and
family of a man who'd been killed by the
police what is the justification for
that do you have uh do you want to get
to the bottom of who who at the highest
level knew about the detail of what's
going on because that hasn't come out
yet in this report absolutely it's very
very important that we do this was under
successive government since this went on
but also I'd like to know why did this
continue there was no justification in
the first place but there certainly was
not the justification for it to continue
for decades as it has done it should be
disbanded and I very much agree with the
point that the Metropolitan Police has
shown itself to be absolutely unfit for
purpose in every respect and should be
disbanded as well
yeah my name says Steve Hadley I'm the
former assistant general secretary of
the rmp union and I was spied on I'd
actually wanted a spy cops claim he was
homeless and came and stayed at my house
a half camp that they build the
Metropolitan Police for Easter board and
lodgings but I had one of them who
actually came to Derry with me during
the peace process they came to Dairy
state in my family's house and obviously
World Trade unionists I was blacklisted
for over a year when they gave my
details to employers organization and
the employers organization made sure it
didn't get any work for over a year and
this is absolutely appalling you know
you can throw about red herrings about
terrorism no terrorists here there's no
terrorists here we're all campaigners
and a democracy which we're supposed to
be able to do in a democracy and it
actually it shows up what the state is
all about and the state are increasing
its players the police and both coming
in is going to increase their players to
do things again people better watch out
because we're sliding on the
authoritarianism
like a personal statement then I think
they were winded up yeah so
um
do you want to say something do you want
to say something
uh solicitor for um coordinator of the
non-state lawyers group I just want to
confirm that one of the reasons for for
your viewers that Jessica is wearing a
face covering is not because she wants
to conceal her identity from The Wider
world it's because she has on anonymity
as do a number of other women to protect
their identities at the hands of having
had relationships with undercover
officers
um Jessica you will hear from in Trump
too in uh which due to take place in
spring 2024. now this is a watershed
moment for all non-state core
participants who've campaigned long and
hard to get to this stage it's taken
eight years to get us to an interim
report published today it couldn't be
more significant but what is even more
significant is next step what happens
from now trance to
as I said we'll hear from the likes of
Andy Coles Bob Lambert who went on to
father a child there are a number of
significant officers and deployments
going forward and so we all need to look
to the Future what happens next
it's taken eight years to get a
published report from the inquiry that
looks at not only the deployments the
managerial role but also it goes up to
modules two B and C looked at governance
and the interaction with the SDS
managers and the home office and the
documents so far as you if you've
scrutinize the report show this goes to
the upper echelons of government that's
why it's a watershed moment